وعن اجراء دبلوماسيين الامريكيين من
السودان قال مستشار الامن القوميه
الامريكي
انه تم وضع جميع المعطيات امام الرئيس
ومنها احتمال استمرار الصراع في السودان
مده اطول واشار الى ان الرئيس بايدن وجد
الفرصه سانحه لتنفيذ اخلاء اجلاء الناجح
فامر الجيش بتنفيذه
لقد اتيحت فرصه للاخلاء اولا لانه اصبح
واضحا لنا ان هذه عمليه قابله للتطبيق
ويمكننا القيام بها وادارتها وثانيا لانه
اصبح من الواضح ايضا ان هناك احتماليه بان
نشهد شكلا من اشكال الصراع الذي قد يطول
امده واخيرا كانت هناك اعتبارات اخرى لها
علاقه بالمده التي يمكن فيها لموظفين
البقاء في السفاره في وقت يحتدم فيه
القتال ويصعب الحصول على الامدادات
وعن احتمال تعرض ميناء بورتسودان الذي يتم
منه اجلاء المواطنين الامريكيين لاي
تهديدات على مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي
جاك سوليفان انه تم ارسال قطع بحريه
عسكريه
لمواجهه اي حاله طوارئ محتمله من هذا
النوع واشار لان الطريقه لبورتسودان ما
يزال امنا للامريكيين
بدانا بنقل اصول بحريه قباله سواحل
بورتسودان لمواجهه اي طوارئ محتمله هذه هي
الطرق الرئيسيه التي نقدم بها الدعم
لمساعده الامريكيين الذين يريدون المغادره
وهم في طريقهم للاستفاده من ذلك وكما قلت
فقد بدانا نرى الامريكيين يصلون الى
بورتسودان